I moved to town to be a songwriter my
goal was to write hits for people I was
not a very good student but I excelled
randomly in writing and I always had a
really good knack for whether it was
like essay you know like short story
whatever you had to write in school
and I just had a knack for it and I was
obsessed with it like knowing that I had
the ability to create a story or make
something up or say something in writing
was always like really important to me
for whatever reason and now I know why
like that was just a like that was the
gift that God gave me I guess was my
interest in writing or whatever and um
but so I I that's it was always riding
and then
um the record like the the artist thing
you know people say doing the artist
thing that came around the time like
Morgan's up down was a hit like because
that was my first number one as a writer
and it was his first number one as an
artist and he was at big loud and I was
writing other songs for other people at
big loud and that's when they kind of
came to me and and they were just like
if you know do you want to do the artist
thing if your [__] like pops off like it
that your life changes you you
understand I mean like your life changes
forever and and I just didn't know like
I had an offer on the table and I sat
with it for months because I didn't know
if I wanted to to do it I was I'd had
some success as a writer and I was like
man this you need to go write a [__]
song and then go play golf every day or
something and and uh I just got done
reading The Alchemist and that book it
talks about opportunities and Omens and
stuff like that a lot and so I had that
in my head because it it kept kind of
getting brought up of like you know like
are you gonna sign this record deal and
blah blah blah and then I finally just
said I I'm gonna do it because I didn't
want to regret it later you know having
you turned it down or whatever
I think it's awesome that you that you
did choose that I mean you know like
Mississippi has a lot of great writers
yeah you know I mean over time some of
the greatest writers are from
Mississippi and uh yeah Eudora Welty I
think he's from Mississippi right yeah I
think so
um dude and then you've got Elvis oh
yeah Robert Johnson who arguably created
rock and roll with the blues both my
parents went to State we were a
Mississippi State family but I moved to
Nashville when I was 19. I went to one
semester at a junior college called East
Central Community College in Decatur
Mississippi but uh no I didn't go to
state I actually went to uh Middle
Tennessee down here in Murfreesboro
and you got your degree from there yeah
I did oh wow commercial songwriting dang
really yeah she just went and took a
class on it yeah I mean it's like a poor
man's Belmont you know what I mean yeah
um like all the kids all the belt the
kids that didn't get into Belmont which
is like you know the big music I mean it
literally sits at the end of music road
down here
um but yeah I mean and the songwriting
class was like whatever and I've said
this before and I feel kind of
uncomfortable because I know there's
people watching it probably that go to
MTSU there but like when I was there it
was like there was no filter so it was
like a bunch of people that just weren't
very good and so like it was like okay
today we're going to learn about riding
a verse and it's there's got to be
structure and each line has to rhyme
it's just stuff that you like most
people knew but there were a couple kids
in there that like got it you know what
I mean like you were you like
you had to play a song you wrote every
week and they'd critique it and talk
about it and this and that the other
yeah and and there was some people in
there were horrible and but there were
some kids in there that were really good
but you could tell like that was what I
took away was like the people that had
it had it but if you can't like learn it
like you can't in my opinion like I
don't know if you could like say man I
owe all of my songwriting success to the
songwriting class at MTSU because it's
like songwriters it's like any other
form of writing it's like everybody has
that weird internal voice and that's how
they write and stuff and I feel like
people are just born with that
yeah I think you can hone things yeah
and you can like fine-tune them you can
Whittle them right you know you could
put a little bit of you know you could
put something in a crust you know you
could put a icing on something yeah but
you got to have something you got to
have the the natural kind of thing I
think but I learned a lot about the
industry there like record deals and
Publishing I mean I learned a ton about
all that stuff and like even recording
studio stuff like I got all of that all
of that stuff from MTSU yeah and then
the first time you hear those things in
business it's not the first time you've
ever heard them you and Laney wrote wait
in the truck no so I so she she did not
she did not did not write it okay yes so
you write the song with other writers
right okay yep
um
just it's like going to work and you
just you know go in a room and throw out
your ideas and sit around and write a
song now say you walk in a room right
and you see the other writers in there
is there sometimes you're like all right
I'm gonna put a certain ideas and
sometimes I'm keeping some in totally oh
yeah oh dude like if you're this is like
if you have a like balling ass badass
idea like I'll sit on that until I know
I'm in a room because if you throw it
out especially in Nashville like La it
can be a little greasier where like
people will take back ideas but you just
don't do that really in Nashville and
like like uh it's not his dog eat dog
let's just put it that way as it is in
L.A and
but like I'll wait until I'm with some
of my buddies or people that will
completely grasp a cool idea so you know
you're gonna nail it because I've made
the mistake of throwing out a really
good title with some people that could
that just couldn't latch onto it as well
as maybe other people could and you just
kind of ruin the idea and then you can't
really write it again or you're an
[__] right because other people are
attached to it and that sort of thing
and you get then then that's when like
you'll you know then if you did write it
10 years later then you got to add these
people because they were there when you
know and they're like well I said that
line and use that in this song too but
yeah there's definitely times like
waiting the truck's a perfect example so
Hunter Phelps is like one of my best
friends and I wrote that with him and
Jordan Schmidt who's also one of my best
friends I'm pointing that one because
Jordan lives right down the road okay
um and Hunter and I kind of came up with
that idea together and we knew Jordan
was a really incredible writer and that
that was the time to bring that idea out
and ride it with some money definitely
that's wild man that's cool yeah
interesting because I guess in the
beginning you might go in is put all
your eggs out there and the other two
people one of them shows up hung over
one of them is pre you know not prep
could be they just found out they're
pregnant right yeah [__] ruined yeah
their day is wrecked yeah exactly
uh and then you're like damn man you
just don't get it to fruition yeah and
it dude it breaks my heart when I have a
great idea and you can you kind of ruin
it because then you're just like
[__] I just missed out on like 200 000
because I had a hit idea and I just
ruined it on on these people it happens
dude you just kind of beat yourself up
about it and like
this and that some people even go home
and completely rewrite the idea and make
it better and be like send it back to
the people you wrote it with and you're
like I like this you guys can be on the
song but I read completely rewrote the
song or whatever does that happen
sometimes where somebody will write it
to other people are in the room and they
get a part of the credit and that's that
yeah the the rule in Nashville is drop a
word or say a word take a third you know
like
it doesn't matter if you're having a bad
day and and that there's like
it always evens itself out because like
you go into a room with two other people
and one of the guys sits over there and
doesn't say a word he's still on the
song he still has a third of the song
like freaking boo Wordly over there yeah
right Bradley yeah like uh sitting over
there like [__] yeah I'm just not
saying a damn word just staring or
something but then there's times where
you might not be on your A game and
somebody else two of the other guys are
guys or girls are killing it and yeah
yeah it's just like a Nashville rule I
know in La like they have lawyers they
have people like sitting in on rights
like paying attention to who said what
and then they like get in and they try
to like negotiate who contributed the
most and that's like the percentage they
get that hasn't made it here yet I hope
it doesn't miss sounds stressful
ugh it ruins everything La will ruin
anything please keep writing and making
cool Music Man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one